on the israeli side of this fractious
border the residents and the farmers
have gone
replaced by police officers and armored
vehicles
and on the other side of the border
militants send rockets from the gaza
strip into israeli territory
white exhaust streaks the sky
followed by thuds and booms as israel's
air defense system knocks some from the
sky
[Music]
in southern israel everyone knows the
drill there is red uh siren go go go
sorry we gotta go
when we stopped at this checkpoint we
were ushered into a makeshift shelter
the rockets fired by a militant group
called islamic jihad
how often does this happen well
okay we've
just come out of the shelter where the
soldiers seem to spend a large part of
every day that doesn't bother them but
they told us they don't like the way
they're portrayed in the west as the
murderers of innocent civilians on the
gaza strip
they told me this situation isn't
israel's fault
yet health officials in gaza say dozens
of civilians have been killed in a
series of israeli airstrikes
residents in the settlement of jabalia
in north gaza say seven children were
killed in one explosion
the aunt of one boy expresses her
outrage here
look at these kids they did nothing it's
a massacre my nephew was only a kid she
said
but the israel defense force said it had
nothing to do with the strike in jabalia
and released this video to back their
claim the explosion caused by a
malfunctioning rocket fired by islamic
jihad they said few would accept that in
gaza however
the israelis say they have neutralized
their opponent over the past three days
killing two senior officials including
commander khalid mansour
thousands of people took to the streets
in gaza to mourn him many calling for
revenge
but the israelis say they are entitled
to defend themselves
who are islamic jihad so islamic jihad
are the palestinian wing of a global
jihadi organization similar to al-qaeda
their main objectives is the destruction
of the state of israel through violence
and terrorism and developing uh islamic
rule and a harsh extreme version of
islamic rule
now the egyptians have secured a
ceasefire on this war-torn frontier
but the situation is volatile and a
temporary truce is not a solution
john sparks sky news in israel